so why do you think the rich should pay
more in taxes why did you buy the latest
iPhone why did you pick your current
partner and why did so many people vote
for Donald Trump
what were the reasons why did I do it
so we also kind of question all the time
and we expected to get an answer and
when being asked we expect ourselves to
know the answer to simply tell why we
did as we did but do we really know why
so when you say that you prefer George
Clooney to Tom Hanks duty is concern for
the environment is that really true so
you can be perfectly sincere and
generally believe that this is the
reason to drive your choice but to me it
may still feel like something is missing
as it stands due to the nature of
subjectivity it is actually very hard to
ever prove that people are wrong about
themselves so I am an experimental
psychologist and this is the problem we
were trying to solve in our lab so we
wanted to create an experiment that
would allow us to challenge what people
say about themselves regardless of how
certain they may seem the tricking
people about our own mind is hard so we
turned to the professionals the
magicians so they're experts at creating
the illusion of a free choice so when
they say pick a card any card
the only thing you know is that your
choice is no longer free so add a few
fantastic brainstorming sessions with a
group of Swedish magicians and helped us
create a method in which we would be
able to manipulate the outcome of
people's choices this way we would know
when people are wrong about themselves
even if they don't know this themselves
so I will now show you a short movie
just showing this manipulation so it's
quite simple so the participants make a
choice but I end up giving him the
opposite and then we want to see how do
they react and what did I say
so it's quite simple but see if you can
spot the magic going on and this was
shot with real participants that I don't
know what's going on
hi my name is petit ha okay I'm gonna
show you pictures like this and you'll
have to decide which one you find more
attractive okay and then sometimes I
will ask you why you preferred that face
okay ready yep yep and why did you
prefer that one smile
one of the left again this one just
struck me interesting shot since I'm a
photographer I like the way it's light
and looks but now comes to trick this
one
so they get the opposite of their choice
and let's see what happens think he
seems a little more innocent the one on
the left you know I like her smile and
contour of the nose and face so it's a
little more interesting to me in her
haircut this one likes a smoky look
better I like to smoke a look
this one what made you choose him I
don't know he looks a little bit like
The Hobbit and what happens in the end
when I tell them the true nature of the
experiments yeah that's it
they stop to ask a few questions sure
what did you think of this experiment
was it easy or hard um it was easy easy
yeah during the experiments I actually
switched the pictures three times was
this anything you noticed no I didn't
notice anything no no no switching the
pictures as far as yeah you were
pointing at one of them but I actually
gave you the opposite the opposite one
okay when you know shows you how much my
attention span was and did you notice
that sometimes turning they experiment I
switch the pictures no I did not notice
that so you were pointing at one but
then I gave you the other one no
inclination of that happening yes did
not notice thank you
okay so as you probably figure out now
the trick is that I have two cards in
each hand and when I hand one of them
over the black one kind of disappears
into the black surface on the table so
using pictures like this normally not
more than 20% of the participants detect
these tries and as I saw on the movie
when in the end we explain what's going
on they were surprised and often refused
to believe that the trick has been made
so this shows that this effect is quite
robust and a genuine effect but if
you're interested in solved self
knowledge as I am the more interesting
bit is okay so what did I say when I
explained these choices so we've done a
lot of analysis of the verbal reports in
these experiments and this graph simply
shows that if you compare what they say
in a manipulator trial and with a non
manipulator trial that is when I
explained a choice enormous choice I've
made and one where we manipulated the
outcome we find that they are remarkably
similar so they are just as emotional
just as specific and they are expressed
with the same level of certainty
so the strong conclusion to draw from
this that if there are no differences
between a real choice and a manipulated
choice perhaps we make things up all the
time but we also done studies where we
try to match what they say with the
actual faces and then we find things
like this so here this male participant
he preferred the girl to the left he
ended up with the one to the right and
then he explained his choice like this
so she's radiant I would rather have
approached her at about and the other
one and I like earrings and whatever
made him choose the girl and left to
begin with it can't have been the
earrings because they were actually
sitting on the girl to the right so this
is a clear example of a post-hoc
constructions so they just explained the
choice afterwards so what this
experiment show is okay so we failed if
we fail to detect that our choices have
been changed we will immediately start
to explain them in another way and what
we also found is that the participant
often come to prefer the alternative
that they were led to believe they liked
so if we let them do the choice again
they will now choose the face they had
previously rejected so this is the fact
we call choice blindness and we've done
a number of different studies we've
tried consumer choices choices based on
taste and smell and even reasoning
problems but what we all want to know is
of course does this extend also to more
complex more meaningful choices like
those concerning moral and political
issues so the next experiment it needs a
little bit of background so in Sweden
the political landscape is dominated by
left wing and a right wing coalition and
the voters may move a little bit between
the parties within each coalition but
there's very little movement between the
coalition's and before each elections
the the newspapers and the polling
institutes they put together what they
call an election compass which consists
of a number of dividing issues that sort
of separates the two
collisions things like if tax on
gasoline should be increased or if the
13 months of paid parental leave should
be split equally between the two parents
in order to increase gender equality so
before the last Swedish election we
created an election compass of our own
so we walked up to people in the streets
and I'll see if they wanted to do a
quick political survey so first we had
them state they're voting in tension
between the two coalition's then we
asked them to answer 12 of these
questions and they would fill in their
answers and then we would ask them to
discuss so okay so why do you think gas
on tax on gas should be increased and we
go through the questions then we had
color-coded templates that would allow
us to tally their overall score so this
person would have one two three four
five six seven eight nine scores to the
left so he would lean to the left
basically an Indian we also had them
fill in their voting intention once more
but of course there was also a trick
involved so first we walked up to people
we asked him about the voting intention
and then when they started fill in we
would fill in a set of log answers going
in the opposite direction we would put
it under the notepad and when we get the
questionnaire we would simply glue it on
top of the participants own answer so
there it's gone
and then we would ask about each of the
questions so how did you recent air and
little state the reasons together we
will sum up their overall score and in
the end they will state their voting
intention again so what we find first of
all here is that very few of these
manipulations are detected and they're
not detected in the sense that they
realized okay you must have changed my
answer it was more the case that okay I
must have misunderstood the question the
first time I read it
can I please change it and even if a few
of these manipulations were changed the
overall majority was missed so we
managed this with 90% of the
participants answers from left to right
the right left their overall profile and
what happens then when they are asked to
motivate their choices and here we find
much more interesting verbal reports
than compared to the phases people say
things like this and I'll read it to you
so large-scale governmental surveillance
of email and Internet traffic ought to
be permissible as means to combat
international crime and terrorism
so you agree to some extent with this
statement yes so how did you recentiy
well like as it is so hard to get at
international crime and terrorism I
think there should be those kinds of
tools and then the person remembers an
argument from the newspaper in the
morning like in the newspaper today it
said they can like listen to mobile
phones phones from prison if a gang
leader tries to continue scream from
incite and I think it's madness that we
have so little power to that we can't
stop those things when we actually have
the possibility to do so and then it's a
little bit back and forth in the yen so
I don't like but they have access to
everything I do but I still think it's
worth it in the long run see if this
person if you didn't know that this
person just took part in a choice -
experiment I don't think you would have
question that this is the true sort of
attitude of that person and what happens
in the end with the voting intention
what we find dowon is also clearly
affected by the questionnaire so we have
Desmond's shifting from left to right or
from right to left we have another 19
that go from clay voting intention to
being uncertain some go from being
uncertain to clear voting intention and
then there is a number of participants
staying uncertain throughout and that
number is interesting because if you
look at what the polling Institute's say
at the the closer you get to an election
the only people that are sort of in play
are the ones that are considered
uncertain but we show that is a lot much
larger number that would actually
consider shifting their attitudes and
here I must point out of course that you
are not allowed to use this as an actual
method to change people's votes sort of
before an election and that we clearly
sort of we debriefed them afterwards and
given every opportunity to change back
to whatever they thought first the what
is chose this that if you can get people
to see the opposite view and engage in a
sort of conversation with themselves
that could actually make them change
their views okay so what does it all
mean what do I think is going on here so
first of all a lot of what we call self
knowledge is actually self
interpretation so I see myself make a
choice and then I try to when I'm asked
why I just tried to make as much sense
of it as possible when I make an
explanation but we do this so quick and
with such ease that we think we actually
know the answer when we ask why when we
answer why and as it is an
interpretation of course we sometimes
make mistakes the same way we do we make
mistakes when we try to understand other
people so beware when you ask people the
question why because what may happen is
that if you ask them sort of so why do
you support desire this issue why do you
stay in this job or in this relationship
what may happen when you ask why is that
you actually create an attitude there
wasn't there before you ask the question
and this is of course important in your
professional life as well or could be if
say you design something then you ask
people
so why do you think this is good or bad
or if you're a journalist or asking a
politician so why did you make this
decision or if indeed you are a
politician and try to explain why a
certain decision was made so this may
all sound seem a bit disturbing but if
you want to look at it from a positive
direction it could be seen as showing
okay so we're actually a little bit more
flexible than we think we can't change
our minds our attitudes are not set in
stone and we can also also change the
minds of others if we can only get them
to engage with the issue and see it from
the opposite view and in my own personal
life since starting with this research
so my partner and I we've always had the
rule that you're allowed to take things
back yes because I said I liked
something a year ago doesn't mean I have
to like it still and getting rid of the
need to stay consistent is actually a
huge relief and makes relational life so
much easier to live anyway so the
conclusion must be know that you don't
know yourself or at least not as well as
you think you do Thanks
[Music]
you